(light music)
- [Narrator] This is
the giant garter snake.
They're endemic to the central
valley wetlands of California
and considered an aquatic species,
but with the loss of
wetlands in the region,
the garter snake is no longer
found in 98% of the areas
it once resided in.
(light music)
Considered the largest of
the garter snake family,
they can grow to be more
than five feet long.
While they are venomous creatures,
they pose no risk to humans.
Their mild venom subdues its prey,
which consists mainly of fish and frogs.
These snakes are brown or olive-colored,
but can easily be spotted
by their yellow stripes.
They are secretive and
difficult to approach
and are known to dive into
water before an observer
can get too close.
Conservation efforts to
create artificial wetlands
are underway to try and restore
their dwindling populations.
This is the giant garter snake.
(light music)